[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will rank the 10
highest grossing Godzilla movies ever
which means we will include the Touhou
movies the most diverse movies and
TriStar as well so let's get into it
number 10 Godzilla Tokyo SOS
2003's Godzilla Tokyo SOS is the 28th
installment in the Godzilla franchise
produced by Touhou Studios it is a
direct sequel to Godzilla against
Mechagodzilla the movie features
Godzilla Mothra and Mecca Godzilla
referred to as Kiryu in the film The
Plot revolves around Kiryu undergoing
repairs and modifications while the
government deals with Godzilla's
continued attacks and in the end along
with Mothra Kiryu fights Godzilla
ultimately sacrificing itself to defeat
the Big G this movie made around 22.7
million dollars worldwide
number nine Mothra versus Godzilla this
is a 1964 Japanese kaiju film directed
by ishiro Honda it is the fourth
installment in the Godzilla franchise
and was praised for its themes of unity
and greed the story revolves around the
discovery of a giant egg wash ashore
after a typhoon they learned that the
egg belongs to Mothra a colossal insect
God and a prophecy saying that the
destruction will follow when the lava
hatches so as Godzilla attacks Japan
Mothra comes to help but is Kilt
fortunately later two lava from her egg
hatches out and they trap Godzilla in
silk this movie is re-released two more
times making a total of 22.8 million
dollars
number 8 Godzilla vs destoroya this is
the final installment in the heisei
period of the Godzilla franchise
released in 1995 directed by takao
okorawara the film centers around
Godzilla's heart which is nearing a
nuclear meltdown posing a threat to the
Earth at the same time a colony of
mutated creatures called destroy emerge
and wreak havoc in Japan the Japanese
self-defense forces must devise a plan
to eliminate both Godzilla and the fast
evolving Destroyer Kaiju the film
features the death of Godzilla and the
growth and Rebirth of Godzilla junior
into an adult this movie made 24.8
million worldwide
number seven Godzilla 2000 this is the
24th film in the Godzilla franchise and
the first movie in the Millennium period
the story revolves around Godzilla who
is seen as a force of nature in Japan a
UFO lands in Tokyo and confronts
Godzilla revealing its intention to
invade Earth it transforms into a
monstrous creature called Olga but
Godzilla fights back and ultimately
defeats Orga with his Atomic breath the
movie received mixed reviews and was
released in Japan in December 1999 and
in North America in August of 2000 this
Millennium movie made about 28 million
dollars in total
number six Godzilla vs MechaGodzilla 2.
this is the 20th film in the Godzilla
franchise and the fifth film in the
heisei era the story follows the United
Nations Godzilla countermeasure Center
as they built Mechagodzilla to stop the
G-Man Godzilla is drawn to the
creature's psychic call leading to a
battle between Godzilla and the
Mechagodzilla the ungcc uses baby
Godzilla as betulia Godzilla into
another fight but Rodan interferes
Godzilla becomes supercharged when Rodan
sacrifices itself ultimately defeating
the Mecca Godzilla is then reunited with
baby Godzilla and the two monsters head
back to the ocean together this movie
made around 36 million dollars
number five Shin Gojira this is the 31st
film in the Godzilla franchise and the
first film in the raywar era the story
revolves around a sudden appearance of a
gigantic monster in Tokyo which evolves
whenever it is attacked or when it needs
to it is revealed that the creature
named Godzilla is energized by nuclear
fission and poses a significant danger
the movie explores themes of bureaucracy
political decision making and the impact
of nuclear disasters Shin Godzilla was
released to a critical Acclaim in Japan
becoming the highest grossing
live-action Japanese movie of 2016 and
also touhou's biggest Godzilla movie it
made more than 78 million dollars in all
number 4 Godzilla 1998 this is the
TriStar American monster film and the
story revolves around Dr tautopolis and
NRC scientist as he investigates Gojira
in New York City Godzilla believed to be
a mutant created by nuclear testing
wreaks havoc on the city while the
military attempts to stop it as the
creature reproduces and its Offspring
boasts a threat to the world Nick teams
up with a French agent to locate and
destroy the nests with the help of his
ex-girlfriend and news reporter they
alert the military and large a final
attack on the creature the film received
negative reviews but grossed over 379
million dollars worldwide
number three Godzilla king of the
monsters the monster verse Godzilla king
of the monsters is a sequel to the 2014
movie and follows Dr Emma Russell and
her daughter Madison along with
eco-terrorists planning to awaken the
Titans giant Masters that they believe
can heal the Earth but this led to the
Awakening of a space-born Titan Monster
Zero who in turn battle Godzilla and
call out the other Titans to destroy
Humanity Godzilla who was almost killed
by an oxygen Destroyer weapon was
reinvigorated by a nuclear weapon and
had his final showdown in Boston killing
ghidoro once and for all the film
received mixed reviews and grossed 386.6
million dollars worldwide
number two Godzilla vs gong another
monster verse entry Godzilla vs Kong is
a 2021 American monster film directed by
Adam Wingard it is the fourth film in
the most of us series and a crossover
between the Godzilla and King Kong
franchises KO who initially appeared in
an earlier movie of the master verse
which is called Skull Island in
discontinuity is brought out from a
dying Skull Island to help humans
explore the hollow Earth but then all
things go sour as he faces off against
Godzilla and then Mechagodzilla comes to
The Fray and they both attack team to
kill the giant robot and finally made
peace the movie received positive
reviews and grossed 470 million
worldwide
and number one Godzilla 2014 this is the
first monsterverse movie and the second
American live action Godzilla movie
after the TriStar film the movie
revolves around the story of Godzilla an
ancient alpha predator and the emergence
of two parasitic monsters got mutos it
begins in 1954 as Godzilla is lured into
Bikini Atoll to be killed with a nuclear
bomb but it survives and maybe he is
energized by it and that in 1999 Monarch
scientists discover a similar monster
skeleton and two giant spores in the
Philippines these are the murals and
Godzilla battles the murals in San
Francisco in 2014 saving the city and
potentially the world the film was well
received by critics and gross 529
million worldwide
so those are the 10 highest grossing
Godzilla movies anyway I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe to
push us through the YouTube algorithm
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel take care fam